(synthesizer)
(twangy country music)
(boat motor)
- Woah-hoo-hoo.
- Day five. Everyone's
in a great mood.
Well, not everyone, but most
of us are in a great mood.
A couple people are
in a really bad mood.
I guess you could say a
majority of the people
are in a bad mood but a few
of us are in a great mood.
I'm not feelin'
so great myself so
a couple people feel
great, a majority feel bad.
Overall, not a good
day. Things can change.
That's the thing
about a day, man.
It'll getcha.
(upbeat synthesized music)
(splash)
(Instrumental country music)
- We're in Kentucky and
this show is all about
what's the dumbest way to
make the world a better place.
So I tweet out, "Does
anybody want to get married
on a jet ski?"
and within 24 hours a
couple responds, "Yes".
They fly themselves
out from Seattle.
Like, just ready for a real
hot, wet, American marriage.
It's gonna be fuckin' awesome.
(audience laughing)
- A comedian on the open
water for a good cause
detoured over to Green
Turtle Bay in Grand Rivers
Kurt plans officiated
a wedding, in fact.
The couple flew in from Seattle,
just to have the
comedian marry them
and good luck to 'em.
- So you're getting
married on a jet ski.
Did you get engaged
anywhere exciting?
Like on a hang glider?
- It was actually,
like, at a bus stop.
- Oh, that's so romantic.
- Um-Hmm. (laughs)
- So it kind of combines
everyone's loves,
public transit, and a romance.
- Um-Hmm.
- And I have one last
question for you.
So I was wondering
if Li'l Minnow
could be your Maid of Honor?
- Sure. (laughs)
- You alright with
that Li'l Minnow?
- Love it.
- Alright. Great.
- Can't wait.
- [Comedian] Hey Johnny.
Have you ever been
on a jet ski before?
- (Johnny) First and last.
- (laughs) First and last.
- Yeah.
- You don't plan on going
back on a jet ski ever?
- Nah.
(laughing)
- A lot of your friends and
family couldn't be here today.
- Um-Hmm.
- And I was wondering if
you would take Li'l Minnow
as your Best Man?
- I would definitely take
Li'l Minnow for my best man.
(romantic music)
(boat motor)
- Little Minnow, make it rain.
(music fades)
- You may now be seated.
(light wedding music)
Johnny, do you promise
to love and cherish Ola?
- I do.
- Ola, do you promise to
love and cherish Johnny
for the rest of your days?
- I do.
- I now pronounce
you man and wife.
(trumpets)
You may kiss each other now.
(audience clapping)
Ladies and gentlemen,
may I present to you
for the very first time,
a married Johnny and Ola.
(audience clapping)
(cheering)
(wedding song)
(jet ski engine)
(music finale and fades)
- [Male] Get in there.
(dramatic music)
(splash)
(music ends)
- They take off, and then
immediately capsized.
(laughing)
Immediately, just
slowly flip over.
He lost his wedding ring.
It just came off and went
to the bottom of the lake.
It was very surprising.
(audience laughing)
You know the thing about this,
the happiest time of their life,
immediately ruined.
- One good thing about
capsizing on your wedding day,
cuz now you've both held each
other while almost dying,
that's a bond stronger
than anything.
Roustabout.
(jet ski engine)
(upbeat country western music)
Now gotta get back on that
great old Mississippi River.
M-I-s-s-I-p-p-I.
Roustabout.
(waves)
- So now, we have to make 150
miles on the Mississippi River
which is, 150 miles
in a car is nothing.
On a jet ski, it's like
doing squats for six hours
while a weirdo tries
to rip your arms
out of their sockets.
And that weirdo is you.
(laughter)
So the majority of this
is just multiple hours
of me just jet skiing by myself
with no one to talk to.
Except I have a mic on,
so I can talk to no one
but have it be recorded.
(laughing)
So I'm just talking to
myself for about eight hours
of grueling exercise.
(upbeat music)
- Interesting fact, Eddie
Vedder owns most of the eddies
in the Mississippi River.
Along the river's edge
where trees are growing,
is actually crumbled
up graham crackers.
Teddy Grahams.
I'm gonna catch this duck.
Fuck. Who knew that a duck
could fly 60 miles per hour
but did you also know that
a duck has a corkscrew-like
penis so once it's
inserted into a female duck
she can't get away.
And then he holds her under
the water for up to five
minutes while he
has sex with her.
You think ducks are nice.
They're fuckin' assholes.
All of this is broccoli farms.
The catfish in
this lake are said
to have a rejuvenating property.
That's a lot of the
locals crush 'em up wet
and rub them all
over their genitals.
That's why this town got
the name "Old Stinky Dick."
Not a lot of people
know that Mark Twain
was a real piece of shit.
(splash)
One of the advantages
of being on the river is
you can just take a
shit wherever you want.
Can everybody turn around?
(upbeat music)
It's gettin' windy.
(thunder)
You can see from
these storm clouds,
that we're probably
gonna get a dousin'.
(threatening music)
And then finally we're
only 30 miles away
from our destination
and a storm starts
comin' up the river
and now things come to
a head at this point.
There's been a constant
battle between me
and the marine crew.
And the marine crew
are like safety first,
as they should be.
They're like, "Just get
the boats out of the river.
You can fake it,
you can just pretend
like ya did all this."
And I'm like, "No, I'm the
weirdo who wanted to do this
in the first place."
(laughing)
So I kinda forced the marine
team to head into the storm
which was probably
not a great idea.
(laughing)
(upbeat suspenseful drums)
Don't let the rain
cramp your style.
The rain hurts your
face a lot. Wooh!
Some people run away
when rains pelting them in
the face at 35 miles per hour.
I like to think of
it as really painful
taps from God.
Bring it hard, God! Bring it on!
(suspenseful music)
Is this normal rain?
(jet ski motor)
Why is the rain still hurting?
- [Voiceover] And after
needle-like rain for hours
and temperatures
that drop 20 degrees,
we finally make it
to our destination.
(thunder)
And everybody's
fuckin' furious at me.
(Laughing)
Like, everybody's pissed
off. Nobody's happy.
But you know, we
fuckin' made it.
We made it. And you know what?
Fuck that marine
team, they're pussies.
(audience laughing)
(audience claps)
I'm just kidding,
they're all ex-military
so they will kill me.
(laughing)
- [Male] Hold it right
there for a second.
Hold the trailer there.
- [Male] Hey.
- [Male] Good.
- And once again on dry land.
I am very cold.
- [Male] Cold?
- Yeah.
(camera falls)
Oh. You alright?
Good save.
(upbeat synthesized music)
(synthesizer)
- I made it 150 miles.
Now it's time to make
the world a little bit
of a better place.
Click on that link. Donate
to Heifer. Do it now.
(footsteps fade away)